hey guys welcome to the evident kids in
podcast the podcast that is in its 23rd
week
without an intro we feel good about
[Music]
[Laughter]
we're struggling to come up with things
to say after the show the show that you
know
yeah well didn't we like abandon it for
a while we did a bit for a while are you
just like randomly start recording when
I was still on my phone yeah that was it
I got a few bye words before Caitlin's
ready well welcome everyone hopefully
there are a few new people here because
we're gonna try to push this to a
broader audience cuz we have been
getting like the requests to make this
episode from for a long time and we have
a lot of things to say here we do we do
so much that we've given a couple talks
on it already yeah yeah well if you're
new welcome hello I'm Evan I guess that
was kind of obvious we make videos on
YouTube we have our main channel where
we do a lot of making we have a gaming
channel we have this podcast channel and
who knows we might start another channel
one day the possibilities are endless so
for our regular listeners this podcast
is gonna be a little bit different we're
gonna be going kind of like really
in-depth into one subject it's probably
gonna be a longer podcast and we
probably won't have time for a game on
this line no story times no go get super
excited because this is something that
we talk about all the time the two of us
so much it's it's a lot it's in their
heads a lot we also talked about all the
time to all of our friends that we've
made in this space I mean we probably
are going to where they probably talked
about this oh yeah we've probably seen
our fellow content creators more than
most of our other friends recently this
because we've like given douve so deep
into this world so we're gonna be
sharing like how to start your YouTube
channel there's a lot of tips that we've
picked up how to grill your YouTube
channel and then how to monetize yeah so
this should be a three-part series are
we breaking this into three parts no no
all one episode my water I'm prepared we
can take a break midway through okay
taxi okay but but also like going more
in depth in didn't like overview of what
we're going to be talking about like go
over how to decide what content to make
at the very beginning because I feel
like a lot of people jump to how to grow
yeah but there's all these foundational
things that I feel you need to figure
out before you can start implementing
strategies to grow because the
strategies are not the same across the
board and they're completely dependent
on like what you're making and that like
once you know what you're making in your
approach to YouTube that will guide
everything else like what equipment you
get what schedule you need to keep like
you promote your videos and where you
promote your videos yeah where your
communities are it's like that is the
foundation upon which you will build
your entire career if you if you turn
this into a career who knows or you
could just be doing this for fun we can
cover that too but like that's the most
important part and that's what we put so
much of our thought into even now yeah
you know and we're continually like
shifting and adjusting that like base
upon which we're standing yeah and then
we're gonna go into tips for making the
content itself yep some tips for making
the content some some tips also for the
actual launch of your channel cuz that's
another thing we put a lot of time and
thought into was the strategies behind
that and then we'll get into growth on
how to grow it which is probably the
part we get asked most about yeah but
then also like if you're gonna turn this
into a career you have to have some sort
of a strategy on how to monetize and
there are plenty of ways to monetize and
probably the best is to do all of them
it's a trial trial try all of them see
what works best for you and your
audience and try go going into
monetization fair
early I think oh well get in there
that's not part three of this podcast
alright so I think that like why we want
to give this talk in particular is
because we started our channel with
intent to make it a business we wanted
to like work together we wanted to be
together
so from the beginning we put these
strategies into place yeah and I think
like if you talk to a lot of different
channels especially people who today are
successful back when they started a lot
of people just started it kind of for
fun or just as a hobby and you know back
then
being a full time youtuber wasn't as
common of a career so a lot of people
didn't have that in mind and so
sometimes the sometimes people did have
strategies for growth but sometimes it
just kind of they fell into it you know
yeah not that they weren't working hard
to work on their channel but it might
not have been the immediate priority
from day one and I think those like
immediate strategies are the hardest to
figure out because once you have growth
you know it's yeah it's self fuels so
because we started from that zero
subscriber mark with making it a
business in mind I think we have some
good strategies for other people that
are starting at that beginner mark yeah
and on the topic of monetization we went
full-time by ADK subscribers on YouTube
do people put in their jobs and our bank
account didn't like suffer tremendously
you know it wasn't a bad decision
because I know some people just like
trust that they're gonna be caught by
the community and trust that they'll
grow in the future but we were able to
go full time at 80k but that was much
risk without too much risk yeah yeah so
we're gonna kind of dive into that and
we're gonna keep all of these tips as
broad as possible so that no matter what
type of channel you are if you you know
our maker make gear if you're make a
channel like us or if you're going into
like beauty or gaming or whatever
whatever you're most excited about it
should be applicable for all of those
different types
okay so what type of content are you
gonna make the most important thing of
this entire talk go okay so I when we're
thinking about what types of content you
can choose to make from are you look I'm
sorry for anyone just listen to the
audio of this so so when we think about
where your content can fall and what
type of content to make we almost kind
of picture it in like a two by two
matrix
yeah on one end you have educational
content versus entertainment content and
all you know the varying mix percentages
in between yeah on the other axis you
have broad content versus niche content
and you know the variations in between
and I think that giving some examples of
each would be kind of useful
so entertainment that might be comedy or
video games or vlogs or Beauty they're
primarily like shared and enjoyed in
different like ways as opposed that
education people watch it for fun yeah
my words are good whereas education
would be like 3d modeling tutorials or
how to boil an egg or how to sew on a
button well but those are very specific
things in general like science video
essays and DIY type of contents are like
the general categories of I don't feel
like you can just say that that's
education because a lot of the science
and DIY and video essays I think of our
more entertainment than an education
true-true well broaden each content this
is an easy classified we I think we can
agree on this so like making and DIY are
like a broader category but like within
that you can go into woodworking or
metalworking or welding well within that
you couldn't woodworking you could do
hand tools only yeah so you can kind of
I keep on focusing it down or on the
more like general categories you can do
vlogging but then within that there's
niches of
travel vlogging and within that there's
niches of travel vlogging in foreign
countries and within that there's like
blogging in foreign countries with kids
yeah so there's like you can kind of
nice day
again and again and again even with in
comedy you can have like comedy or you
can have skip comedy and are you like
video games themed a skit and like where
you start the channel is really really
important because it's painful and
difficult to change later on yeah it's
not impossible because we it's not a
policy there's growing pains
yes and there's advantages to all four
of these like quadrants you know so with
entertainment I think that you have
probably one of the broadest audiences
the highest growth ceiling and with
education a lot of people seem to want
to watch educational videos but they
just don't in total get viewed as much
unless they have a heavy dose of
entertainment yes yes so it's like again
on that spectrum and with broad content
I think it's great because it allows you
a lot of flexibility you know like
especially like if like you know you did
the youtube landscape changes because
like if you started a Minecraft video
game channel a while ago you might have
found like really good growth and
success but then if minecraft fades in
popularity or gains popularity then
you're gonna struggle to change you know
but if you had a general gaming channel
then you could grow and same with any of
these different topics yeah and I will
go back a little bit one thing you said
earlier is that like education videos
don't get watched as much and I think
like in total they probably might you
know because like that is still a huge
reason people go to youtube but I think
like for any individual education
channel especially if you have a lower
amount of entertainment mixed in like
I'm just gonna take it to the extreme
let's say you're just 100% education
there's no fluff there's no funny
commentary it's just just learning how
to do the thing I think you're gonna
have a smaller audience for that
specific thing and when you're doing
education I feel like especially if it's
you know there's not entertainment mixed
in you have to kind of be more of an
expert and the thing you're doing and
you're not likely to be an expert in
equal expert in like
how to keep plants alive or how to
powdercoat your Yeti and how to build a
computer you know so like you're you're
probably gonna be a little bit more
niche by nature unless you are mixing in
entertainment and then like how well you
know your topic is doesn't matter as
much be less experts because we're not
telling people what to do yeah we're
showing people how we did something and
in a hopefully entertaining way yeah
yeah but I think that one advantage that
education really does have is it
provides an immediate kind of tangible
value to the viewer which i think is
easier when you're starting out because
if you just start out from day one and
you're like hey I'm vlogging I'm funny
and I'm a funny person I feel like
people will look at you with your zero
subscribers in your one video and be
like who's this person I don't I don't
care what you're having for lunch
yeah but introduce and of course people
can like you know there are breakout
successes but I feel like for a lot of
channels that are that are more
entertainment based it helps to kind of
like build upon that and it might be a
little harder to start from the very
beginning yeah and same the same was
kind of nice and broad content I think
that if you choose a niche especially if
it's one that's seeing a lot of growth
right now you can experience a lot of
growth right away yeah because you can
be a bigger fish in a smaller pond yeah
so like Simone yurt says the biggest way
to stand out in your field is to create
a whole new field and then you are
immediately the expert in that field you
know so it's like the more nice you are
the more you can stand out but hopefully
you choose a niche and you go about it
in a way that doesn't limit you in the
long term because the broader category
you kind of fall under the more you can
kind of grow and change and evolve over
time whereas if you really nice down it
might be harder to grow outside of that
means anything so I would just depends
on like knowing yourself you know so
when we started our channel we knew we
wanted to make stuff so that that was
kind of committing to a category
somewhat but it was a very broad
category but we knew we would want to
bounce a
around and try a bunch of new things all
the time so from day one we really
varied the types of maker videos that we
did but you might be someone who is like
I I have been collecting rocks my entire
life and I want like I would feel no
greater pleasure than to share my love
of rocks with the world for the rest of
my life and you know your thing and its
rocks it sounds like you're a completely
different type of person this loves
rocks I'm convinced now tell me more
about rocks see my passion yes and that
kind of goes to something else is like
make videos about things you're
passionate about yeah that's a bit of a
virus it's really cliche but it's kind
of like what you're saying earlier with
the Minecraft videos if you only do
something to chase a trend trends change
yep and it's not guaranteed that that's
always gonna be successful and just
again like we were saying with change
change is kind of hard to make and so if
you end up getting yourself stuck doing
a certain type of videos simply because
you thought they would be successful but
then the trend changed and you're and
the reason why change is hard is because
consistency is really important the
viewer that has subscribed you kind of
needs to know what to expect and
hopefully they know what to look forward
to and like if when you push that
publish button and it goes out to your
subscribers you want every single one of
them or as many as possible to be really
excited to watch it because if you build
up a subscriber base around an
expectation of one thing and then you
change and then you're you're providing
them a different thing they won't click
it as much and then YouTube will take
that as a sign that your content isn't
good because YouTube can't know
everything all they can see are numbers
and data and when your viewers and your
subscribers are sending YouTube data
that your video isn't good bad that's
that yeah exactly
well and I think when it comes to
consistency and I think when it comes to
consistency don't don't make that
that doesn't mean that you have to
follow the exact same recipe your every
single video and there are channels that
do that and do that successfully but it
just means that there needs to be some
element that is consistent yeah so for
us you know our projects vary but there
are almost always projects and there's
always the two of us and there's always
the two of us and we're always being
like pretty goofy that part has changed
because we started out more in the on
the educational side with a dose of
goofiness and now that's true but I
think as long as there's some elements
that are consistent and then and you can
find your own consistent elements like
maybe it's your editing style maybe it's
your filming style your cinematics are
always like off-the-charts crazy or you
always have this dry sense of humor in
the voice-over or whatever it is there
can be a lot of different things that
are consistent that tie all of your
videos together so like yeah I like
Caitlyn said like findable your most
passion about it
passionate about but also lean into the
things that make you kind of weird or
unique or quirky or whatever it is like
think about like what you are known for
at this job or in high school or within
a certain group of friends and kind of
like lean into that part of your
identity to kind of like tie everything
together or if you don't want to put a
personality in then that can be your
thing - who knows so another thing is
just do a lot of research we still watch
a lot of YouTube and it's all very
important research very important but
but seriously like watch a lot of stuff
pay attention to why you're watching it
pay attention to is that the person's
personality is it like great
cinematography is it really good
storytelling and pick what elements you
like and you can mix and match those
into your own type of content or you can
just use that research to to like learn
best practices in the type of content
you want to do like let's say you want
to do cooking videos you might watch
some binging with babish you might watch
bone Appetit you know you can
start seeing the things that are
consistent between the channels you like
that seem to do well yeah and you can
don't just watch like really good
channels you can also watch kind of like
smaller channels you can see like what
you would change and that's like a
really good practice to get into yeah
and I think then another thing that
really helps with figuring out how to
develop your own unique style let's say
that you really like binging with babish
and his general aesthetic or something
and you pull a lot from there but then
you also watch like this vlog channel
that has this thing that you think is
hilarious to pull in where you watch
this gaming channel and they do a lot of
you know special effects or noises or
sound effects you can kind of like pull
like a lot of different inspiration from
different types of channels so sometimes
watching videos that are outside of the
image that you are trying to get into
will really help like diversify your
content and make you stand out
yeah and find what resonates with you
don't just say like oh this one gets a
lot of views this one gets a lot of
views almost gonna do that no no like
fine it needs to be genuine yeah yeah
cuz if you are setting this up as a
career you might be doing this for the
rest of your career
and if you don't like it it's not
sustainable I know we're gonna be saying
this a lot but I think we just need a
hit on this point it's like repetition
is the key to learning right now for
those of you listening we're just
pretending to hit things with a hammer
yes yeah like so for one example I think
that a lot of people are inspired by
Casey and I staff yeah I mean tog Rafi
is awesome at storytelling is awesome
and you might think like wow that looks
so fun I want to do that but then you
you start filming and you realize wow
making content almost every day is
really hard it's really hard to make my
life interesting as fun as it looks when
he's doing it it's kind of stressful to
me because I'm just eating cereal today
and it's not that exciting I'm not in
New York I'm not any of my own seems
like not everyone can make that type of
content you know yeah and and you might
get bored of it like let's say that you
like start committing to daily content
people expect that and then you get
bored or tired you know so it's like
like stay yourself up
for the sustainable long-term right from
the beginning yeah yeah yeah I was gonna
say inland like know that things
probably will change and we'll probably
talk about change a little bit later as
well but definitely do your research so
that you go into it the best you can
yeah right with all of that covered now
we're gonna talk about how to start
making your content not how to grow yet
but like tips for how to start because I
think that this is a huge barrier for a
lot of people they know they want to
make YouTube content done the
brainstorming they watched a whole lot
of YouTube and they're still watching a
lot of YouTube hopefully watch our
channel too maybe a little bit but I
mean you know like how to start is
really intimidating because it's not
that natural of a thing for a lot of
people yeah so I think you know putting
yourself out there first I'm just
talking to a camera as weird putting
yourself out there on the internet feels
really weird and so this is intimidating
to you and that's what's holding you
back but you still want to do YouTube I
think one thing that you can do is start
practicing on a less intimidating
platform so let's say you're making
stuff and you want to start a maker
Channel but that's very scary you can
start posting your projects on Instagram
and I think that's awesome because or
for a few reasons one taking Instagram
photo is generally gonna take a lot less
work than recording and editing an
entire video so here's less there's last
time commitment to you can even even if
you you are doing little videos it's
like a 1 minute max so you're kind of
capped in terms of how much you're
expected to put out there 3 you can
start finding your voice and kind of
like practicing in this you know this
little like training wheels kind of
stage and finding your voice not only
just like literally speaking but like
writing and your style is like like how
you engage with the community and all of
that there's a lot that goes into it
well and that's the next thing too is
you can start building your own
community so that when you do launch
your YouTube channel you have a
community a community like a group of
people to launch it to
so you're not just starting from scratch
you already kind of have people that
you've been interacting with and like
making a YouTube video takes so much
longer than whatever you were we're
gonna make the YouTube video about so if
we're making a thing making a thing and
a video at the same time it takes twice
as long if you're going to the store and
you're gonna be filming a vlog about
your day you're gonna get half as much
done because filming takes so much time
and then there's editing so it's like
like also it's like with Instagram you
can kind of soft launch different ideas
and see what ideas really stand out in
the community and you can go through a
whole bunch more things in that form
faster and find your footing in that way
yeah yeah yeah I think also like the
fear of being on camera can be very
intimidating and so a few tips to make
that less scary is you can just record a
video with no intent of putting it
online you can just record it you can
edit it and that's what we did with two
of our vlogs we did and then we ended up
posting them but but it takes a lot of
the pressure off you're gonna be more
natural on camera because you're not
worrying about oh my god everyone's
gonna see this and like can they tell
that I'm sweating you know so it just
takes a lot of the pressure off and
gives you practice and yes it might seem
like you're putting all this work into
something that nobody sees but hey if it
turns out awesome you can use it as one
of your videos but there's no pressure
on it yeah I mean we were so awkward at
the beginning like looking back at our
first video Oh
oh my gosh we were just like putting
handles on an IKEA dresser and it took
us so long so many takes I swear the
intro to that video took us three hours
filming yeah yeah we did it so many
times and we just left the camera
running the whole time there's a lot of
footage it was so much footage and also
like I think that one thing that's
important to keep in mind is you you can
decide not to be on camera too much like
being on camera isn't like a necessity
to make a youtube video yeah
think of like clickspring yeah for
example he does really satisfying
machining videos tons of followers he's
not really it's just his stuff you know
and I think that another thing that like
because YouTube like the a lot of
YouTube is like bubbly and a lot of
personality and like generally pretty
positive I mean we're pretty positive
people but that doesn't mean that needs
to be who you are there there's this one
channel that I kind of love it's like a
cartoon animated Channel and the
narrator's just kind of grumpy the whole
time he's grumpy
he has like kind of a harsh sense of
humor and it's hilarious yeah so like it
you don't need to be a certain type of
something in order to find success one
thing that we've learned over time
that's really important to creating a
youtube video is figuring out like the
format of the video like what your story
is before you start recording then you
know kind of what to record what to
time-lapse through what to talk about
and kind of like how to shape it all
from the beginning and if you kind of
know this story and the arc it's so much
less stressful than just like starting
and filming everything yeah and I think
it's something that in the beginning
it's probably easier if you actually
formally write down this stuff and
towards the end you can or once you have
more practice it can be a little looser
you can keep track of it more in your
head but for for example our channel
there's kind of a built in story arc
with every video because we are making
something in almost every video so there
you start with raw materials there's
like trials and tribulations along the
way so so that part was decided but in
the beginning we would actually write
down a shot list everything we needed
solaced and like general words we wanted
to say sometimes I'm just like 100
percent scripting it was mostly
voiceover yeah so I mean we might happen
to capture some in the moment stuff but
we we planned the voice-over and we play
on the shot that's so crazy to think
back and remember cuz I remember like
not liking like voiceover session right
sat down and I recorded lines I did not
like that I am bad at like
cuz I would I would edit it I would do
my own voiceover yeah for the whole
thing just so I could keep going on the
edit and I didn't have to keep I would
choose like okay which voiceover spots
should Evan take but I talk a lot faster
than you and so and we would have the
video perfectly timed to the music so I
could like extend the scene so I'd be
like okay Evan say next we're gonna glue
down the thing and then we're gonna wrap
the edges and then we're gonna do this
thing to this thing and you're like next
we're gonna glue down I was saying my
words but see that's something that we
started with that was our crutch for a
while then we evolved past that so we
did yeah but I think it can be helpful
to kind of storyboard out your video yes
especially having a beginning middle and
end like having a conclusion really
helps a video stand out and in in
someone's mind you know it's like oh I
watched that and they did this to this
like even if there's like mini plot
points within your videos you know like
try to set things up
and I think one one way to set things up
is you predict something you do the
thing and then you react afterwards and
that's like kind of a pretty easy
template you can apply to almost any
type of video yeah so it's like if we
are about to do a resin pour we will
chitchat say how we think it's gonna go
then we do it and as we're doing it
we're reacting to how it's actually
going
so like predictions and reactions are a
huge way to add or story as opposed to
just like doing the thing and not saying
anything or even if you like you're a
travel vlogger let's say that you're
going to this place and you've you've
you're telling the camera like man I've
heard about this place
I hear it's the best pizza in an entire
world and you get there and you try it
and then you react is it actually the
best piece in the world or is it
actually really bad yeah there's so much
story there's so much more story there
than if you just went and you're like
and I had pizza at this place it wasn't
great but if you were like I'm going to
like the highest rated pizza place in
this city and then you go and you're
like you know it really didn't live up
for me there's so much more story there
this is the best pizza I've ever had in
my entire world I'm part of
I'm gonna words yeah so it just it adds
a lot more and again this that may not
be applicable if you're doing like
strictly educational based stuff but I
think you can even take some hints of
that and apply it to education like yeah
if you're if you're doing a cooking
channel or a cooking video and you're
like okay this is where you flip the
pancake and so if it's if it's not
cooked enough it's gonna fall apart if
it's cooked too much it's gonna be burnt
on the bottom so let's flip it and see
use a little bit Co see it cracked a
little bit yeah that means it's yeah and
you can teach or like let's say you're
teaching welding there's a lot of things
you can teach from like like saying how
it's gonna go and then show pointing out
the flaws and what you just did or
whatever yeah same same but different
same same but different
yes true but also it's like one way to
like like this is like kind of like a
little hack on how to make your videos
more entertaining if you're going after
that you can just put yourself in
interesting or funny situations which is
one thing we picked out from William
Osmond when we did the collaborations
with him very first collaboration yeah
we're definitely putting ourselves in
funny situations but yeah that's a great
way to kind of just think like okay what
would be funny I'll just do that thing
yeah even if it's like slightly
uncomfortable who knows yeah I mean
we've like taken you know we made DIY
super soakers we took them to the park
cuz that's gonna be a lot more be
funnier yeah it was like more can happen
there than ever does in our backyard
yeah you know and there's a wedding in
the background which was like kind of
hilarious that'd be awesome
their wedding at a public park with lots
of other people around they're asking
for a water gun fight in the background
it wasn't just us like disrupting a
wedding that's also like kids playing
Pokemon go and well I think that that
can like transition us into pacing tips
pacing I think this is probably one of
the hardest things to figure out it's
really hard to communicate you watch a
video and you're like it's wrong yeah
yeah it's like
sometimes you can say oh it's it's a
little slow or sometimes you can say oh
they rush through that too fast but it's
it's hard to touch on like why something
is just right yeah and I think that the
reason why pacing is so so important to
get right is because YouTube videos are
people's active time they're usually
like you know on their phone just
looking at the phone looking at the
video or they're on their couch or
they're like researching like like they
they just punched a hole in the wall or
something and they're looking at how to
fix it and they just want to fix it
Evans referencing to our how to patch
the drywall video a lot of people
comment I just punched a hole in my wall
Thanks
a lot of people we get those comments
like quite a lot so it's like this is
this is people's active time so you're
supposed to like a podcast where it's
kind of passive listening where people
can be driving to work or making dinner
or doing yard work and they're listening
and yeah it's like we have room to turn
and be a little okay then people just
turned you up to 2 X feet but I think
that like general tips that we can give
to kind of get you started along that
direction you can cut out dead spaces
like don't leave in these long moments
and lingering pauses now you don't wanna
go too far with all the jump cuts
because I think that's some people like
some people do that like Philip DeFranco
I think that's a lot of jump cut I think
I think I'm gonna backtrack a bit okay
I'm not gonna say cut out all your dead
space I'm not gonna say jump cuts are
bad I'm gonna say make sure you have a
balance of like have the video be slower
when it needs to be slower and faster
when it needs to be faster so if if
you're having a heart-to-heart with the
camera and you're saying you know I'm
about to try this really hard step or
I'm about to do this challenging thing
here is here is why I'm scared to do
this and I'm a little nervous and this
could happen
this could happen you want to leave in
your put your dramatic yeah I'm just
imagining good jump cut through all of
that it'd be horrible yeah it would be
it would be terrible totally lose the
effect you know and then you do the
thing and maybe there's not too many
dramatic cuts you you do the thing and
you just see how it goes and it's
terrible
and then so you have to do it five more
times to get it right those five more
times you speed through those yeah you
know just to I know this is kind of
vague cuz I'm just talking about some
miscellaneous thing that you were doing
on this video but there's definitely
times where you want it to be slower in
times where it makes sense to just like
get good things going yeah
and I think that also like even with
comedy pauses with comedy can be some of
the best moments no it's gone the moment
is past
yeah so I think that uh I think another
way to kind of like keep the pace up
because part of it is about timing like
slower versus faster but part of it is
mixing up the type of footage so if you
have a mix of you know talking points
where you're like a talking head talking
to the camera mixed with b-roll mixed
with time-lapse that's gonna help keep
the pacing up as opposed to if the
entire video is just talking heads which
I mean we're doing out but this is a
podcast yeah so if you're watching you
could also be listening right now I
think that one one thing where it's
really really important and this is kind
of going in to kind of SEO type
analytical type things but the intro and
the outro are by far the most important
parts of a YouTube video because the
intro that's where you try to catch
people pull them in and so you don't
want to lose them too frequently because
if someone makes it all the way through
your video and to another video
they didn't exit on your video they're
exiting on someone else's video so like
yeah so we've even noticed some channels
have super abrupt endings it's just like
they're talking talking in them haha
you ended and you made
hundreds on the way through you know
yeah so it's like you don't want to go
too far down the hackey way but like
like keep down the asks don't ask too
many things at the end and or the intro
or they don't ask you anything no no
whenever I because we follow some like
you know YouTube related subreddits and
one of the most common pet peeves when
people are asking for advice is when
people have all their asks upfront in
the intro people are like asking you to
subscribe and like and ring the bell
before they've even started the video
yeah yeah and when it comes to actually
filming all this stuff one tip that we
have found really helpful is to edit
either in your head or for real as you
go and this is some people do this and
some people don't we've tried it both
ways where we film the entire video and
then we added it or we've done where we
film a couple hours and then we edit and
then we film a couple hours and we edit
and we like the latter because I feel
like it helps us with pacing it's a
little bit easier to actually edit it as
you go and then you know like well I
just spent a whole lot of time talking
so this next part I should kind of speed
through it a little bit yeah or like
let's say you try to say something four
times and you know in your head the very
first part of the first sake was good
and the last part of the last take was
good keep that information in your head
you can just like go slap those two
parts together and then keep going
because you don't want like too much in
your head while you're trying to make an
film and everything and honestly in the
beginning you're probably gonna film way
too much I know we did and I think that
in a way it's almost a little bit easier
to film too much odd kind of err on the
side of filming a little bit too much
rather than too little because you're
going to go back yeah in the beginning
it will take longer and you will film
more than you need and like going back
to the pacing you have to be a little
bit brutal on the editing floor you like
even if like you thought you did like a
really clever shot and took a long time
but it just doesn't work in the Edit
you gotta be brutal as yourself gotta be
brutal you gotta cut that out
you know I think one thing you can do
well maybe this is getting a little
ahead of myself sometimes
hard to know yourself especially when
you've been like editing for forever yes
like pubes oh my gosh yeah I go into
editing for you see um you've rewatched
the same scene 20 times and the things
that made you chuckle the first time
like you don't crack a smile at the 20th
time and you're like I have no idea this
is good anymore so it really helps to
have somebody else that you can show the
video to that hasn't been as deep in the
Edit as you have that's me that's Evan
because Caitlin does all of our editing
but it could be like a family member or
a friend or oh my gosh if you have like
a kid you can show it to there are gonna
be the most that's when we lost them
yeah yeah all right well I think that
takes us all the way to gear and
technical I think that we get a lot of
questions about this too and I think
it's less important than people think
but at the same time we don't still want
to like say that's not important then
like skip over it will give some like
actually some tips I think the biggest
tip is that like the thing that matters
most is audio by far by far yeah you can
get away with pretty crappy video as
long as your odd is okay and I think the
reason why is cuz like watching subpar
video doesn't necessarily like hurt your
eyes I just might be slightly annoying
but listening to bad audio actually like
a noise yeah and also like like if it's
too loud or not clear enough or it's too
soft or there's too much background
noise it's just like I just I just can't
do it and most people can't do it
they're not gonna forgive you it doesn't
matter what you're doing if audio is
terrible
yeah yeah so I think that like you know
along those lines even if you're just
starting with your phone you can get
like a shotgun mic you can get a lav mic
but like start there if you're gonna
like really get going on a YouTube
channel
start with audio and I think like you
know it's hard to if we just list a
bunch of products we use it's kind of
hard to retain audible yeah we'll listen
all in the description below
yeah we'll put it all in the video
description with links to all the stuff
that we use but also like think about
again it all goes back to what ty
of content you're making like yes is it
do you need 4k do you need autofocus do
you need stabilization do you need that
flip lens for that selfie mode there's a
lot of things that like will be decided
by what type of content you're making
that is very true
yes yeah so like if you're doing if
you're vlogging
kaylynn you can talk about editing a
little bit there's not that much to
share though no I mean people ask us
what we use we use premiere sorry
there's tutorials online I would suggest
just kind of learning a few very very
basic basics like when I say basic I
mean like how to cut Clips and how to
drag them that's that's pretty much all
you need to get started with editing how
to cut the clip and how to drag it on
the timeline yeah you can do that almost
any program there's a lot of free ones
out there and everything else don't
worry about like learning everything
perfectly just if you come across
something that you need to figure out
just YouTube search it and there will be
a tutorial on it and you can figure it
out as you go yeah and in terms of music
there are some really good resources we
can share yeah so YouTube's audio
library is probably gonna be the first
place we're gonna recommend people to go
it's huge
there are so many songs that so many
people use and sound effects and sound
effects and they're all like they won't
get flagged by YouTube's system because
they're in YouTube's system that's the
safest place to go there's also places
where you can license music and those
are great sometimes they will still get
flagged because you you're the person
flagging it doesn't know that you have
you know bought the license to it so
things I mean we've used audio blocks
there's also one awesome awesome
resource awesome so many youtubers use
has sounds and musics it's amazing it's
so a website again we'll link to all of
these incompetent is the website
incompetent calm the man's name is Kevin
MacLeod's and he has you Kevin thank you
Kevin so much music it's amazing
most of our songs are his case I just
wanna like I want to look up an
interview now and just like see what his
life
a gift of a person puts so much music
out there for people to use yeah another
awesome place is patreon so we we found
a couple artists that we really really
liked on soundcloud and a lot of times
people will give out their music for
free on soundcloud if you like properly
credit them but a lot of times those
artists also have patreon and you can
get songs that aren't listed on
soundcloud or like more convenient
downloads of their chef where you can
download a whole album instead of tracks
individually and things like that and i
think i was a great resource because
then you're also like supporting someone
yeah i think we should talk about
branding now and again it seems like
Caitlyn's gonna be like telling you most
of the case because she is the expert at
all of the things we've talked about so
far I'm like what am i doing on this
channel Caitlyn share your experience on
all these things okay so now we're kind
of moving away from the how to figure
out what kind of content to make and how
to make it to how to launch that content
yes which is huge huge and I think I
think a lot of people I don't know I
it's one of those things where you until
you do it you don't there's no practice
run you know no yeah you can't practice
launch it and I think that some people
might have like this vision in their
head where you just like make good
content and you upload it to YouTube and
stuff happens and magic things grow and
everyone finds you somehow but you have
to put a lot of thought into the launch
and and the more work and thought and
effort you put into the launch the
better things will go yes house there's
a common theme with all of this just put
in more time and it's better
so as you're saying branding I think is
a really great place to start so in in
terms of branding I mean you don't you
don't have to have every single little
aspect of your brand figure it out but I
think you need a name for your channel
you need a logo and I would say that you
need channel art or that your channel
banner I think that some of that goes
back to letting you know letting your
audience know what to expect
think about that you have a schedule if
you have a type of content you're making
then name the logo all of that like when
someone goes to your page let's say that
like I send you this link and I'm like
check out this channel and you go there
the branding should tell you what type
of channel it is along with like the
videos and the thumbnails and all that
stuff but yeah so before you launch your
channel out there and into the world you
want to have that stuff set up because
people are way more likely to understand
what your channel is about and click
Subscribe if they if you have a you know
nice-looking channel banner and a
consistent logo and I just I mean I just
think that stuff's very important and
it's gonna stick with you yeah and and
if you start with one sort of branding
and you try to change later it can be
really painful we know we've known
multiple people who have gone through
difficult times or at least trials and
tribulations because they try to change
their name and things went wrong yeah
yeah along with that like I would say
once you have your name chosen reserved
all your social media handles on every
single platform there is even if you're
like I hate Twitter I'm never gonna
tweet just get it anyway and then like
let's say that you're like Yamaha 49
[Laughter]
Yamaha man on your youtube but then like
gamma ha man gets taken up on Twitter
that's unfortunate you know and then
when you're trying to give people your
handles you're like follow me at Yamaha
man like forever on Twitter
Yamaha man yeah yeah you want to like
get it as consistent as you can it's
nice that we can say like follow us up
at evident Caitlin on every single
platform if you want to exactly yeah so
so yeah so that would definitely be an
important part before launch I think
also and this goes back to what we were
saying when it we were talking about
going for a test run on Instagram if
you've started test running putting out
your content out
they're in little small doses on
Instagram engaging with that community
and building up that community will help
you have someone to launch to and I
think even just that even if it's not
huge I think we had 500 subscriber or
followers on Instagram yeah when we
launched our channel it's still somebody
it's still 500 people that you didn't
have otherwise well it's somebody you
know it's like find that community if
you're Yamaha man find your fellow audio
enthusiasts engage with them and when
you launch your Yamaha man channel
people want to check out and see what
you've been working on that you've been
like teasing on your Instagram and stuff
you know and I think also tell people
when you're gonna launch yes we we did
do that I'm very glad we did even though
it's kind of stressful because we have
like an external deadline but we told
our friends and family we announced it
on our Instagram that we have a big
announcement coming on this day we told
our friends at work I told everybody and
so then we had to do it because we
talked to so many people who you know
we'll see them at events a year after
year and they're like well I'm still I'm
still gonna start the channel I just
haven't yet and it's like if you if
you've set a date then you have to do it
and then you'll do it and it's starting
a channel is kind of like planting a
tree yeah where it's like the best time
was years ago
the second best time is now I'm so true
but you don't want to keep putting it
off and putting it off because it's
gonna get harder and harder as you do
one one specific thing that we recommend
to people we've talked to who are
thinking about launching a channel start
with a batch of videos because you only
kind of get it's like meeting someone
for the first time you only get one
chance to make a first impression you
know and let's say that you're Yamaha
man and you want to do like reviews of
audio equipment and like events that you
go to around audio equipment and like
other things you want to show people
your full breadth of what you're gonna
be doing and it gives people multiple
chances till I say oh that looks
interesting because if you only have one
video and someone goes your channel
they're gonna meet making the decision
whether to subscribe or not based on a
single video as opposed to multiple
chances and that single video will set
their expectations yes so
if you want people to think you're only
doing reviews of audio equipment because
that's what you want to do then you
might want to have four different audio
equipment reviews but if you want people
to think maybe you're just a channel
that does tech reviews in general maybe
you have one that's audio thing one
that's a camera review one that's a TV
review one that's a whatever and that's
such a stronger message than just a
single video
yeah like actions speak louder than
words are advertising you know and video
speak louder than I don't know the
analogy is breaking down but you got the
point for our channel and we started
with I think one or two home improvement
videos a concrete video a woodworking
video probably one other thing I don't
remember exactly but it was a mix of
different maker videos cuz we wanted to
send that message from the beginning
that we would have a mix of things and
get people more chances to subscribe and
I think another thing or two more
reasons why it's good to have like a
batch of videos one is oh yeah this is
so important actually I think I know
you're going but you're gonna say I'm
about refining your that's so it might
take you a couple tries to feel good
about your editing and video style yes
so our our first video like we talked
about earlier where we added knobs to an
IKEA dresser
I pretty much rieta today entire thing
after we recorded our second video
because after the second one I was like
oh I feel like I'm getting the hang of
this
the first one is terrible and we even
went back and refilmed like intro or
scenes or transitions we redid voice
overs and we had that opportunity to
like get to version two yeah because we
didn't just publish that one video and
then move on and once it's up on YouTube
it's up its there I mean you could
delete it but again like you don't want
to announce your channel and have that
one first impression and then like
delete it and announce it again yeah so
so I think it does help you to figure
out your style if you're if you're doing
a few videos ago it gives you bills you
builds in like a grace period
yeah edit them but I think another
is so when we want launched our channel
we didn't want people to just find our
one video see though that's the only
video we had and think like oh I just
thought you were making it really weird
face your Chinese Jackie and and and we
don't want people to see our one video
and think that we were just a one-off
that that we just uploaded this one
video em whatever we felt like if we had
multiple videos people would see them
and think oh okay these people are
uploading continually and consistently
and this is a thing they are doing it's
not just some couple randomly uploaded a
video yeah exactly
alright guys now guess what time it is
it's how to grow Oh what everyone came
here for how to grow we've been talking
for all this time about all this
background stuff like it's important
it's the most important but this is what
you've come for
how to grow this is the most difficult
part of everyone's career it's like
growing from zero so many people have
said that this is the most painful part
of the process like when your abs zero
the first 100 is the hardest the first a
thousand is the hardest then the next
10,000 is the hardest but like once you
get going it kind of the momentum builds
upon itself I'm not gonna say it really
gets easier but it gets more rewarding
the growth aspect of it like builds upon
itself yeah you don't have to work as
hard for every single view yeah it's
kind of like when you find a product on
Amazon you know and it has zero reviews
you're like should I get this but I like
the more like watches you get the more
subs you get it's kind of like the
community buying in and endorsing you in
the way yeah if you see a video pop up
on your home page and it's like this
changes everything
and there's zero views well this changes
everything and it has 5 million views
like what does this change
exactly exactly changed I think the
biggest thing is people aren't just
gonna find you
yeah specially when you're at zero you
know
especially when you're at zero there's
so many new channels so many new videos
uploaded every single day and when you
start you're just one of those and so
you really have to work to bring people
to your channel when we first started
80% of our views were from outside of
YouTube so that means places where our
video was embedded outside of YouTube
and all of that was done by us we were
sharing it on Instructables we were
sharing it on Reddit we were putting it
on our blog and this kind of goes back
to like what type of content you make
finding those communities knowing where
that content is shared how it shared the
kind of like etiquette around all of
that like promote it but promote it like
where it makes the most sense for your
videos and your community you know I
mean yeah so as as a maker channel
Instructables made a lot of sense for us
yes but it might be different for you if
you're a Travel Channel or a Cooking
Channel or Auto Body Shop Channel who
knows you know but like like one one
thing that I think a lot of people might
overlook is just share with your social
circles share with your friends your
family your co-workers ask them to share
it around like that that might be enough
to like start things moving yeah it's
like it's kind of like what is the joke
where it's like I two guys are running
away from a bear and he's like I don't
need to run faster than the bear I just
need to run faster than you yeah it's
kind of like that in the beginning it's
like you don't have to instantly go
viral you just have to have more views
than other people who are starting at
zero you know to start like building up
your momentum so yeah so whereas right
now us telling like our friends to share
it on social media to share video on
social media might not make a huge
difference but in the beginning it does
make a huge difference compared to your
size yeah and again like I hate to say
this but like I'm not sure if we have
said it yet you have to have good
content I mean well yeah that's a whole
another thing I mean we had a section in
this whole talk about like how to make
your content good it has to stand out in
some way you asked like do whatever but
like all of this is kind of with the
caveat that
it kind of has to be good I think if you
implement some of the tips we talked
about earlier with like pacing yeah
filming tips and having a story or
adding value or serving in each that's
underserved or what have you
yeah but at the same time like it also
has to be good let's just have that as
like an underlying understanding I'm
understanding yeah the reason everyone
just says like well it has to be good
content and no one really goes into it
it's cuz it's very subjective and it's
very hard and there's a your finger and
every single part of it that makes it
there also aren't any like all of the
things we've talked about so far they're
all like general best practices that you
can be applied all sorts of different
content types and all sorts of different
videos but like what makes content good
depends so much on everything it's not
even something I can say like all
entertainment videos should yeah blank
you know okay so sorry I kind of went on
a little tangent there and it's not I
throw it out there okay let's go back to
sharing your stuff so like I said 80% of
our views came from outs from us pushing
it outside of YouTube but our theory is
that the other 20% we got from YouTube
was only because we had a little
traction with that the the views we're
getting outside of it I feel like that's
kind of true like especially because we
were doing like at that point kind of
slightly more niche slightly more
educational content that we're doing now
and we were trying to rely on search too
now when you search and you see a video
with zero views you probably never see a
video with the zero views because
YouTube just won't even serve it up but
like you have to have some views to
start showing up in search and start
trending for different types of topics
and everything like that I think this is
another theory it's just the theory no
one at YouTube has confirmed this but I
think that how YouTube knows what video
you made is by using the data of who
watches your content so like more than
like your tags yeah more than your tags
your tyre tags or maybe like a starting
place but they're endorsed by the people
who visit your video like let's say I do
a woodworking video and everyone who
comes and watches and stays engaged the
whole thing maybe leaves alike maybe
leaves a comment they also like
woodworking club like videos in general
that's going to be an endorsement by
your viewers that your content is
woodworking yeah
80% of views that we were driving drove
the additional 20% because those 80%
brought in viewers broadened data gave
Google information they needed to make a
judgement about our video and then they
could start serving it yes yes yes so
we've talked about this a little bit but
community involvement is very important
for promoting your video so not just
like when you launch it but also to keep
reminding people of your channel every
time you update or upload a new video
you can post about it on your various
social channels and but not only that I
think being just a present and involved
person in the community helps you know
people will see your user name over and
over again if you're being interactive
in your community and that's a reminder
every time and then if they see a
youtube video pop up and they're like oh
that's that person that I keep seeing in
all the comments on all the people I
follow they're more likely to click it
then if they have no idea who you are
and of course never be pushy never
suffer sub never like one like equals
two subscribes or whatever I do not do
no don't don't don't don't do any of
that be be helpful helpful positive or
like you know what would ever like
contribute to provide value and that's
going to be the way to get positive
attention as opposed to fickle attention
yes or just being blocked I think
another thing is like and this probably
depends on the types of videos you're
making but a lot of communities will
have things like challenges you can hurt
as a maiden so like one of the first
things we did there's a maker podcast
called the modern maker podcast and they
had a two two by four challenge and a
lot of people entered in submitted
videos and participating in that it
definitely gave us a boost and
introduced us to a lot more people and
that video became our most watched video
for a while
you know until we continued to like keep
going and move and keep going but I
think that's a really great way to get
extra eyeballs but also just continue to
form relationships in the community
because you'll you'll start to like get
to know and you'll start to follow the
other people participating and like it
can just lead to genuine relationships
and speaking of those genuine
relationships one way to really
establish those even more is to go to
events that's one thing we really enjoy
doing in general and I think that like
we just talked about events like a lot
in our last podcast so if you want like
more thoughts on that we'll link to it
yeah but in general is good to get
involved like maybe volunteer maybe like
you know meet up with some of the people
you you interacted with in that last
challenge you know have meals with
people and that can strengthen those
bonds in general so another way to grow
is collaborations and I we get asked
about collaborations a lot cuz we've
actually done probably more than most
people who considering like the young
age of our channel yeah we've done a lot
we've done a lot of collaborations
here's what we're here maybe a little
bit too much and so we get asked about
it a lot and I think my biggest tip with
collaborations is it's it's not a
guaranteed thing that all of a sudden
your channel is just gonna grow like
crazy it might happen you might not grow
at all and so I think only do a
collaboration if you just want to do it
because you are friends with this person
and it's gonna be fun and if you guys
both grow awesome and if you don't
that's cool you still had a week of
hanging out with you know some of the
friend that you wouldn't have been
hanging out with otherwise and I think
that one of the biggest values we've
gone from collaborations in general is
just learning skills like watching other
people work not like just working with
like you know making because we're we're
involved with a lot of makers like the
back end business side like crazy how
how much people film seen someone film
and then seeing the final product
of their edited video is very
eye-opening or seeing your you know
having a chance to talk to somebody
about sponsors or having the chance to
talk to someone about how they keep
track of projects and all that stuff you
know it can happen at events too but
when you're doing a collaboration
there's a lot more one-on-one time
together and so you can go much deeper
into it but I think people think that
it's just like this magic thing and
therefore they propose a collaboration
and it comes off like it's only for the
purpose of growing so I think if you
want if you do want to collaborate with
someone you need to make sure that you
and that other person have an actual
real relationship first and like also
maybe if you're smaller than the channel
you want to collaborate with yeah reduce
their workload or help out in some way
or or do something that you know provide
something that they might not have been
able to do on their own like if you're
an expert in something then you can
bring that to the table yeah yeah
alright so in terms of the technical
stuff like the backend we're just kind
of not breeze over them a little bit
because I think that there are videos
that touch on this deeper and better do
your research I know that's kind of like
a little bit of a cop-out but we'll
touch on a few little things here and
there yeah yeah so I think that one of
the things is use a lot of the systems
that are in place so you do push these
systems in place and if you're not
taking advantage of them then you're
leaving things on the table I think one
of the things that we've started doing
now that I think is really important is
putting time into your closed captions
especially now that YouTube starts Auto
playing videos on the homepage and what
shows up in the video are closed
captions yeah also closed captions are
one of the things that YouTube indexes
when they're trying to like figure out
what type of video you have so of course
there's things like keywords but
captions are another opportunity also
auto closed captions are not always the
best like that we are vulgar people yes
we curse like sailors and we do not
curse in our videos but that could if
Auto captions are picking up cursing in
your videos and you don't go in and
manually correct it it might YouTube
might think that your channel isn't
appropriate for all audiences yeah so it
might not show you to everybody so
that's definitely one one kind of
back-end thing yeah
to tackle another thing that you can do
is especially like in the beginning if
you're relying on like search to bring
in viewers and stuff if you're an
educational channel or you're doing
something that maybe is trending right
now that a lot of people are searching
yeah do your research on like keywords
like what if DIY book ends is better
than like wooden bookends or that's not
the best example yeah but that like one
thing we we learned again you know we
started as a DIY Channel we learned that
often how-to has a lot more search than
DIY which I would not have expected and
it might not be the same right now it
changes but it's just one of those
things to look into yeah I think also
things like make sure you have a channel
trailer yeah you may not need it
immediately when you first launch your
channel because oftentimes you need
footage from other videos to incorporate
into a channel trailer and not always
but I think it helps but as soon as you
feel comfortable doing that I think
that's another good thing too yeah add
your channel I think have playlists too
like if on your home page all it is is
that single default bar of videos it
looks very empty and you might have a
hundred videos but when someone goes to
your home page they only see five or
four or whatever it is if you have like
playlists with like descriptions in the
playlists which are also searchable by
the way so like you know fill it out
flush things out
also with playlists because a good thing
about playlists is you are controlling
what that person is gonna see next and
they just want things autoplay so
instead of watching your video and then
seeing a bunch of other people's videos
they're more likely to stay watching
your video if they're watching from a
playlist so playlists are great to put
in like the end cards of your videos
then it'll get people on like a track of
videos instead of one or like in the
links and description or wherever you're
putting links in general playlists are
better than a single
yes yes and I think that everyone knows
this but like on the technical side the
thumbnail is so dang important it's it's
more important than any of the other
like backend YouTube stuff we've
mentioned in this section yeah I know
that we kind of get sucked down the
rabbit hole of like trying to find the
perfect thumbnail oh it takes hours
sometimes today just so that we could
take pictures for a thumbnail not for
this podcast I know it's really
important and like it also conveys so
much about your video or badly people
like assume it does yeah so so for
example one one thing that we have been
figuring out again because we
transitioned from more instructional to
more entertainment is most instructional
DIY channels the photo or the thumbnail
is gonna be a photo of the finished
product that sends a message to the
person clicking like here is what you're
clicking for if you want to learn how to
make this here's the thing and when we
started doing or when we started
shifting more towards entertainment and
we always had a little bit entertainment
in there but the more and more we shift
the more we started realizing that that
doesn't necessarily work like people
don't want to see how it turns out in
the very beginning because it's not as
good of a story it's like spoiler cuz
they're there for the journey they're
not there for the finished product yes
you know we're but if you're giving
instructions people don't invest time in
the video unless they know what they're
watching for so I think just know that
like like get into the mindset of the
audience you want to reach with your
videos and don't just apply a default
rule that you think is right because
other people who make similar videos are
doing it you can always like again going
back to the social platform is you can
always do polls you can always do let's
ask your friends and family and also
like knowing what type of content you're
making go all the way back to the very
beginning do your research look at other
channels that are doing well in your
same type of field and look at like how
they structure their thumbnails and
stuff like that yeah for example like if
you're doing entertainment based videos
it's um you know it can be important to
have
a face in your thumbnail because
reactions are more important than the
thing you're reacting to now keep in
mind there also has to be like a strong
cohesiveness between the thumbnail the
title and the content that kind of
consistency and expectations yeah but
also it's like on the analytical and
technical side of things if you have
like this crazy thumbnail and a crazy
title you're like most extreme wipeouts
ever and it's like a kid falling over in
their carts or something like that you
know actually that might be pretty good
maybe maybe it's a whiteboard and you
wipe it off yeah an extreme wipe out
actually really good like you know like
if someone clicks in and they
immediately click out what signal does
that send to YouTube does YouTube that
your thumbnail and title we're
misleading yeah and if someone searches
for most extreme wipeouts they see your
your title and time no they click it
they go in then they go right back out
guess where your videos going next not
there well being the search for much
longer you know I mean so there has to
be that cohesiveness because in the end
at YouTube is trying to like deliver
high quality content that sticky that
delivers and that's accurate and you
don't want to send false messages yes
yes yes so another thing to keep in mind
is scheduling and there's a lot of
different opinions on this so we'll just
share what we found works for us and why
we like to have a little bit of a
schedule and by a little bit I mean a
lot of it helps drive things it helps
keep us on schedule help standardize
things my schedule keeps us on schedule
yes but also like it adds an end point
because I think especially with this one
right here if we didn't have a schedule
should just want to keep on refining it
forever and it'd be hard to ever call it
done it's true it's yeah I think I think
there's like again it probably depends
on your personality but for us there are
good internal reasons to have a schedule
but I feel like there's also good
external reasons so the internal like
you said it helps it keeps us from
putting too much time into one video it
so keeps us from taking breaks or breaks
but it.we we can produce a lot more
because you know every Friday there's
got to be a video out but also you can
schedule in breaks um yeah but I think
externally it helps make your videos
more of a habit for people watching
because if you know in the same way like
you know when the office came on
Thursday nights
I knew Thursday nights I was gonna watch
the office if evident Kaitlyn you know
release of video Fridays like Friday
mornings then I know that's what I'm
doing Friday morning yeah or even if
it's Saturday morning or Sunday morning
you can build conditions around whatever
time it is yeah it doesn't matter what
it is I'm just saying like you pick your
your day yeah and then you know whatever
a day that is you go and watch that
content and then you're not as reliant
on the subscriber bell and the
notifications and all of the systems
that YouTube has in place that sometimes
you know might change but if you know
every weekend I watch this this and this
you know then you'll seek it out you can
stick it out even if YouTube isn't
sending you a notification whereas like
if you're publishing like once a month
or once every two months you might like
not know that someone has published a
piece of content and you won't go search
it out or maybe they publish once a
month for a couple months and then they
publish five in a week yeah you know
your you might not catch all those five
because you're only expecting one a
month yeah and then you know what a
month still has it good it's not a bad
approach necessarily I don't think it's
bad approach to do one a month mark
Rober does one a month I just think it's
he's doing one a month consistently yeah
and he's not all of a sudden like
jumping up to multiple yeah you're right
or skipping tons of months yeah yeah but
like being consistent in general not say
you can't take breaks we take buffer
week sometimes where we like continue to
work we and we still do podcasts and
gaming videos but we don't do our main
channel videos yeah we can get ahead and
so don't feel like the schedule has to
rule your life rule your life but I
think it does help add a little
structure I think it's really hard to do
that at the beginning especially if
you're not seeing the growth that you
want you know it feels like your content
into a black hole but I think that like
it's it's it's pretty important than to
to kind of like think of yourself as
like a full-time content creator and
like put in that work and effort because
if you don't then you probably won't see
that growth yeah and I think that's one
of the hard things because you might
only be getting a few views on a video
that took X amount of hours to make and
a year you're from now your videos might
take the same amount of hours to make
but you get thousands of views yeah but
in that first period you're doing the
same amount of work for nothing and or
for what feels like nothing and so it's
easy to get demotivated do not want to
put on the time to not want to you know
put out as many videos as you can yeah
but like going back to that drywall
video that we talked about earlier that
was the very like in the first batch of
four videos it was in that batch and
that for the longest time was her number
one by far watch video and it's still in
the top five right top five to like five
to seven or five to seven yeah it's
still way up there it's still going
and it's m'as the second video we filmed
and edited and it was in that initial
batch when we had no subscribers or no
views and no money coming from it but
it's been monetized since and it's like
slowly putting it bringing in that
residual money you know so I think just
think of those things think of the
potential of your videos even when
people aren't seeing them initially yeah
and after covering all of that I think
we're gonna like go back around to
dealing with change it's it's something
that we've dealt with some and it was a
little bit painful like at the end of
2018 we started experimenting with some
different types of videos because that's
what we knew we wanted long-term we knew
that that would make us happy long-term
and we didn't exactly know how to mesh
the type of content or make that
transition and we dealt with it by just
like grinding on through it dealing with
the slightly less performing videos
learning those lessons and eventually we
emerged out the other side and
everything has been so much better since
we kind of successfully made that
transition
and we have we have podcasts where we
talk about the transition a lot more
yeah oh that's low
yeah like is it something to keep in
mind and also maybe people who are
watching this have a channel that
they've been going at for awhile and
maybe they want to change my yeah and
and yeah I don't know how much there is
to say about it just because we went
through it and it's gonna be unique for
every single channel and stuff but I
think that knowing that's possibility
knowing it does cost something but in
the long term if you're making the
change for yourself and for those right
reasons it's worth it alright I think
that brings us to monetization okay so
before we go into like monetization and
how to monetize your videos I just want
to share like a little bit of a back-end
on how we transitioned from full-time
and part-time to well our old jobs to
our new jobs and like how we did that
because most people who are going to be
doing YouTube as a career they generally
also have to like think about how
they're gonna make that transition
financially and I think some of the tips
that we have developed and we've thought
about will help you make that transition
less painful yeah yeah okay so I used to
work as an engineer we talked about more
in a previous episode it seems like it's
a theme like this is like we've talked
about a lot on we have and you know when
I was working as an engineer we knew we
wanted to make this transition so I kind
of went to consulting to kind of
supplement that income and mission less
painful well you you switched from
full-time to consulting yes yeah there
was no income and from YouTube yeah
there was no income supplementing our
income of $0 zero dollars but the reason
that you went to consulting is because
then you had a little bit more control
over your schedule yeah and I got paid
more per hour and the main thing we're
trying to do is cut down hours of our
old jobs and increase the hours of
YouTube so that was like one option
those open to me yeah and I was a
graphic designer and I switched from
working 40 hours a week to working 30
hours a week to working 20 hours a week
do
being talked to by my team saying hey
you either need to come back to
full-time or you need to quit so we can
hire someone else and I was like well
I'm quitting so it's that between you
reducing your hours on a consulting
basis from going like five days a week -
four - three - two - one and me reducing
my hours per week we were able to gear
up the channel and still maintain some
income no I'm still it was still kind of
scary because you know we at a certain
point didn't have health insurance
anymore we just have to bite the bullet
and pay for it yeah and you know you do
even though there's part of you that's
like well I can always go back to
another job and we are to our old jobs
or a similar job and we did feel that
way it is still a little scary but I
think being able to ease into that
transition made it a lot less scary than
just both of us quitting our jobs on the
same day and going from full-time jobs
to no income yeah you know and another
reason why we want to share the story is
because for both of us this was very
unconventional at our companies no one
in company was doing what she was doing
knowing that my company was doing what I
was doing but we we made it happen
because it was a priority for us and in
the end even though reducing our hours
at our jobs was scary the thing that
scared us honestly more was looking into
the future and knowing that we didn't do
everything that we could to make this I
give it the best shot possible that was
scarier to us then the transition yeah
100%
and yeah and like you said this wasn't a
conventional path so I guess the advice
there is don't be afraid to ask for
something even if other people aren't
doing it the worst that someone can say
is no yeah yeah okay so that's how we
transitioned from full-time to part-time
to YouTube or oh yeah you got old jobs
to YouTube but we still had to figure
out how to make YouTube actually make
money because like growth there's a
whole bunch of strategies on growth but
there's also separate strategies and
of how to actually make money from your
growth especially if you're not relying
on Adsense alone yeah and I think that
the two big tips that we have are early
on diversify and start with baby steps
earlier on than you might think
because we started monetizing I got
30,000 subscribers yeah we had our first
sponsor at 30,000 subscribers and the
reason why you do that early is because
things might not go smoothly and
honestly it's better to learn that when
you're smaller than when you're a lot
bigger you know like the bigger you are
the bigger you fall type analogy yeah
yeah I mean there's more risk there's
more at risk bigger I think that's one
reason I think another reason is if if
implementing that type of monetization
is a goal of yours the early earlier you
start building that portfolio the easier
it is to continue to build yeah on both
sides on the advertiser side and from
your viewers because if you're you've
you've grown a whole bunch and your
viewers are used to know and know
sponsorships and everything like that
and you start throwing them in then
that's a change you know
and it's maybe an unwelcome one but if
you know people know from the beginning
that that's how you've been able to make
videos and how you're able to make more
videos or better quality videos or what
have you then and that's part of your
identity then it won't be as big about
negative in a way yeah yeah it's
interesting we got a comment today on
one of our videos and I could tell it
was someone new to the channel because
they said man these guys aren't even
400,000 subscribers and they already
have sponsors like well it's actually
very common in the maker community but
it's like we we started so early on that
for our regular viewers it's like not
even a thing yeah you know what I mean
this is this is just how we pay our
bills yeah you know and also it's like
them the earlier you start working with
these companies
the easier it will be for you to
understand the contracts how to
negotiate how to reach out and also the
more brand deals you do and
advertising that you do it's like kind
of a portfolio because the more you put
advertisements into your videos the more
you can show off how you do that in a
way that you know hopefully creates a
win-win all the way around for the
advertiser they are being shown to the
right community the community is being
shown something in a fun way are being
exposed to a new product and for you
you're like naturally tying these two
people together and hopefully everything
works out
hunky-dory I'm happy happy I don't want
to clarify two things real quick one
when you say advertiser you're talking
about sponsors sponsors yeah so that's
like brands that we're working directly
with not advertisers that are
advertising on YouTube yes another thing
we need a backtrack a lot we just
started going down the sponsor point one
was diversify so I feel like we could
talk a little bit about like the
different ways that we make money yeah
okay let's go down and then we can go
deeper into this one okay so let's break
it down like top-level where do we
person personally like to collectively
make money for evidence Island so 60%
are from sponsors yes 15% patreon 15
what did I say you said 15 but it just
sometimes it's hard to tell if someone's
saying 50 or 15 okay 60 percent from
sponsors 15% from patreon 15 from
Adsense 6 from affiliate and or from
merch yes so that's the breakdown for us
and you know I think that's actually all
of it there's land sales and everyone is
gonna do it differently and you might
change like in the beginning we we also
sold products yeah like physical things
that we made so I think that a huge part
of like our like community in general
our selling plans like some people
that's like their entire income you know
yeah and for us we have like a couple
plans or you can sell books or online
classes or like you can have a really
successful website where you sell space
on their way you do a lot of public
speaking and you get paid to do talks
right I think um
I think like testing all of these again
and if you test it a little bit when
you're smaller it's it's a little bit
easier cuz the risks are lower you just
like learn the ins and outs of each one
again and again and again as you get
bigger no no no like like um so it's
like let's say you figure out sponsors
you're like yeah I figured that out then
you also have to figure out affiliate
and you also have to see our merch but
it is worth it it's worth it to like put
the time in and figure that out and you
may test something out like you may try
patreon and say this is not for me I I
don't feel comfortable with the amount
of value that I'm providing to these
people that are paying me money and and
I want to pull out or you might be like
us and be like I friggin love patreon
our patrons are so awesome before we
dive into each individual one I was just
using patreon as an example of things
that you like you might try something
and not like it or you might try
something in lot of it so it's worth it
to try lots of things
well actually I was about to say before
we dive into something but let's
actually dive into each one individually
so let's start with sponsors because I
feel like that's kind of pretty
complicated and it's a big one for a lot
of people including us it's probably the
one we get asked about the most
yeah probably cuz it is it sponsors can
allow you to go full-time with your
channel long before you'd be able to
otherwise any other way yeah like if we
didn't have any sponsors we might just
now be able to go full-time
yeah and that's okay no I think you're
right if we hadn't have gone down to the
sponsor out early on we would be going
full-time now and instead of making 120
videos and our career so far we would
have made less yeah a lot less a lot
less saying when I hardest things is
like how do you connect with sponsors
how do you reach out reach out to them
like like like we are definitely strong
advocates for like taking the first step
in that relationship I know a lot of
people say like no wait for them to come
to you because you get more bargaining
power and there might be some small
truth in that but at the same time like
choosing who you want to work with is so
important to us because
being able to give a genuine endorsement
of a company or a product makes things
so much easier and feel good it's like I
I love so many the sponsors we work with
and it feels nice to be able to give
them like a like I don't know
yeah well also I think like kind of like
what we're we're saying in the beginning
when you don't have any track record
with sponsors they're probably not gonna
reach out to you you might get reached
out for someone wanting to send you a
free product but it's it can be hard to
convince somebody to pay you when you
don't have a track record yet so the you
can you can start working with them
earlier on if you reach out as opposed
to just waiting them to waiting for them
to find you yeah and honestly like it
does take time there is a cost to it but
at the same time who knows when that
brand will just somehow find you you
know it's like it's like going to a bar
and like looking cute in a corner or
something and like hoping someone just
like I don't know I'm not sure if that
makes a lot of sense but just like thank
you too but I probably would have gone
up and approached you because I'm sorry
yeah yeah I think you can start working
a sponsor earlier if you reach out and
of course the earlier you reach out the
less you're gonna get paid cuz you're
not pulling in as many views but we were
okay with that in order to like get
practice yeah
and forming relationships I think that
in terms of reaching out it really helps
to engage with a brand a little bit
before you to send them a message out of
the blue you know like tag them on
social media comment on their thing
that's like because the person who
decides the social media campaigns is
probably gonna be tied somehow in with
the social media like accounts and
everything like that so you know get
engaged with the brands especially like
when you're first starting out and
everything and then maybe send them a DM
send them a message like look up their
contact information the like press
releases or what have you you know like
be proactive about things but also
don't be pushy and weird don't be
pushing weird but I'm gonna um you kind
of breezed over this how we reach out to
them yeah like where we reach out to
them part is DMS but a big one is like
press releases because a lot of times
there's an email on the press release
and that's someone who is on the
marketing team for the company yeah you
can also do some light stalking on
LinkedIn or if you've owned events again
you're not only meeting people you might
meet some range that you're really
excited about and you're like hey I love
your product I would love to do
something with you let's form a
relationship you know and and and be
really positive and I think that one
thing that you want to do is like think
about things from the brand's
perspective they're probably being
approached all the time and you want to
stand out and you want to make things an
easy yes you know like tell a story like
hey I've been using your products for
eight years and I love them and I'd love
to share the story and I have this
project that I'll show off your your
product really well and make it so that
they can say yes yeah lots of back and
forth you know yeah you don't want to
say you don't just want to email and say
hey would you like to work with me you
know like you want to give them reasons
to say yes and feels like you actually
put it effort into it yeah yeah I think
another side of the coin with sponsors
that a lot of people have trouble with
is figuring that how much to charge
because you want to be fair to the
company they also don't want to get
completely ripped off you know so it's
the way we go about it is kind of fairly
standard practice in the industry but
you kind of go by a cost per thousand
views it's called a CPM cost per meal
cost per meal yeah and it's the cost per
thousand views in the first 30 days you
have to the wife and the views of the
last 10 or so average performing videos
yeah
so yeah we have like a calculator for
ourselves but so you just have to figure
out what that CPM is for you and then it
makes pricing yourself really easy and
and CPMs won't necessarily be consistent
between bigger and smaller channels
because the bigger someone is it might
be hard to charge the same CPM when
you're
when you are getting millions of use as
it was when you were getting hundreds of
use cuz it doesn't scale like you can
out price yourself yeah so and it also
depends on the industry like gaming
might have a different CPM than DIY that
you know fashion and you know beauty
community boutique community probably
has a pretty high CPM
but yeah so talk to people who are
around your same size because that's
gonna be a better measure of what you
should be charging rather than talking
to someone who's 10 times your size and
also depends on the type of
advertisement is it product placement is
that full talking points are the talking
points at the very beginning or are they
at the end are they in the middle how
long are they are you gonna have to be
exclusive with the brand you might need
to build in some CPM for that all these
things play into it sounds very
overwhelming that's why you start all
you really you get that experience you
you you figure out what is costly to you
it's very stressful when it's like the
difference of thousands of dollars on
the line because you realize you should
have charged more if you had to say the
ad upfront rather than the ad at the
beginning it's gonna be like $50
difference then you're kind of like oh
well you know no I know a big loss for
me yeah yeah and in general just to give
you a general range to start at maybe
between 15 and 50 CPM yeah so you take
that 15 or 50 you multiply it by the
average views in the first 30 days of
your past 10 videos and then that's how
you get here price yeah so for us like
product placements are on the lower end
and sponsorships with talking points you
know 60-second talking points are on the
higher end and you just kind of like
figure out what works for you yeah yeah
okay cool so let's go over to patreon
because we love hit Rhian we do love
patreon we and this is something that we
started fairly early on too and you know
what from the beginning we were invested
in it we had a vision for it we wanted
to build up a community there and we put
in we put in as much effort
from the beginning compared to now what
are words again yeah we we put the same
amount of effort in the beginning as we
do now even though there are a lot less
people and it's kind of that's kind of
consistent with the videos you put in
effort as if this is your full-time 100%
thing from the very beginning even when
you're not really getting much out of it
because you want to like establish
yourself in a good place from the
beginning and you know let's say let's
say what you do for your patrons you
know one thing we do is we record and
after show after every video it takes us
the same amount of time to record that
after show if there's two patrons or 200
patrons so you just have to be okay with
that in the beginning if that's the kind
of thing you want to pursue and it's
also a lot easier to see the value when
you're small and when you're beginning
because when you aren't getting that
much money from anything patreon you
know is a really great option but as
soon as you're like really really big
starting over from zero on a new
platform it's kind of a lot harder yeah
by the time you're putting into this new
thing when you already know how to make
a lot of money and one huge advantage of
patreon as opposed to like sponsors or
Adsense or anything else is patreon is
very consistent it's super because it
feels so nice knowing that our patrons
are there supporting us it's like a
safety net there's a safety net yeah and
I think there's a couple different ways
you can go about patreon so we've talked
a lot of different people about how they
do it and I've kind of narrowed it down
to three different ways it can just kind
of be a donation box where you say hey I
have this patreon you if you want to
donate to me to help support the channel
this is where you go there's not
necessarily any rewards it's just a
donation box so it's like lower effort
but also lower pay back lower effort
lower pay back then there's the type of
patreon that offers one-time rewards so
that's like if you sign up to become a
patron you get a t-shirt or you get a
sticker or things like that that you
have to as the content creator
you have to deliver those rewards once
per patron but then never again I think
the benefits of those are there's not as
much maintenance per patron but you do
have to keep it does like your effort
has to scale with the amount of patron
so maybe it's not a big deal to send
shirts if you're only getting a few new
patrons a month but if you're getting
like a few every day that could be a lot
of work it could be yeah the other way
is offering ongoing rewards that are not
divvied out on an individual basis they
are like given as a group so that's kind
of what we do because it scales well it
scales well and it is a lot more work
especially in the beginning again when
you don't have that many people but we
use things like after-show videos we do
behind-the-scenes post we do monthly
video chat calls with our top patrons
and these are things that I feel very
comfortable in our ability to scale and
that that works well with us and a bonus
is I feel like we have like a good
relationship with our patrons I think
that ties up patreon I think that going
over to Adsense I'm not sure if there's
much we can really share I mean most
people seem to understand this you get
more views you get more money and
depending on like the type of channel
you run you might get slider slightly
higher CPM or slightly lower that's
what's interesting is that people's CPM
varies just like a standard CPM across
the board so it's like yeah the type of
content you make and also the time of
the year you know in December it's
higher when more companies are spending
money and in January before their
budgets are approved and everything it's
a lot lower that's lots of youtubers
take vacations in January yeah a little
side bonus knowledge there but like
there's it's just it is what it is yeah
you're you're it's not gonna be as much
of an issue if you family-friendly
content from what we've gathered I mean
YouTube doesn't like publish a lot of
this stuff yeah so that's speculation
but so I think we can go into affiliate
a little bit more because really
affiliate is a perfect type of income
source for channels like us where we're
buying things showing how they're used
and making things with them you know
it's like base
the affiliate like income works by you
put a link in your description or in
your wherever you put links and every
time it's like a referral you know it's
like someone clicks it they buy it and
you get like a small percentage back
from the seller yeah so like we use
Amazon affiliates a lot it's really easy
to start with
yeah we're it's super it's super easy to
apply and it's very easy to get the
links you need yeah now one one tip we
did get from someone who started this
started a channel and they started doing
affiliate like very early if you start
an affiliate account with Amazon and you
don't sell enough right away you might
have to reapply my need to reapply later
but it wasn't something we had issues
with I mean it might be different
because we were maker channels it might
be different because we're making it
well we're more likely to click on our
affiliate links because we are saying
here's the thing we made here's the
tools and materials we used to make it
yes more incentive to click yeah or you
can list the the camera you use or your
gear or whatever it is you can kind of
tailor it to your own channel a little
bit but if you're a travel blog it could
be like your backpack and your water but
it's such an easy win win win for
everybody because the people watch and
want to know what you use you provide it
the company gets the sale and you get
some income it's it's it's pretty
self-explanatory yeah so merch let's go
on to merch so I think there's two types
of marshmallow mint in general
print-on-demand or carrying sock
yourself yeah we opted for
print-on-demand
we started carrying our own and it's
surprisingly difficult to estimate what
you're gonna need even when you only
have one design I'm laughing we got it
so far off we didn't know like how many
men's to order how many women's what
sizes and those were the only variable
yes it was we had one design and we got
it wrong yeah very wrong so what that
told us is that print-on-demand is a lot
easier and also when you're you know it
can totally be cheaper to order your own
stock but it's only cheaper if you can
guess it right and order a lot of it at
once at the smaller quantities we were
ordering it wasn't necessarily a better
deal than us just doing it print on
demand yeah we're getting not huge
badges you also have factor in the cost
of your own time like should you be
fulfilling merch or should he be making
more videos and like the disruption of
like shipping out a single shirt in a
day yeah it might be more than you think
shipping is like so much more of a pain
and more expensive and you might think
Amazon completely spoils everybody cuz
like Amazon does it's just free it's
like today and like people expect that
and it's not that but I guess like
print-on-demand it's it's very easy
there's no limit on the amount of
designs you can do whereas if you're
carrying your own stock every design you
add adds another variable you have to
guess about so that's what works best
for us we use printful we'll put a link
to them in the description it'll
probably be an affiliate well most of
our links will be affiliate links as it
is listed but yeah i think i think
that's like kind of the basics of march
yeah again we're getting into things
that for most people it it will be a
smaller portion of your income not
everybody we know some people who do
majority of their income comes from rich
yeah but I feel like when you're getting
started merch will be not a huge part
and probably not something you need to
deal with immediately yeah and I think
that those those topics probably cover
all of the like most widely applicable
ways of earning money don't you think
well I mean I wouldn't say like merch is
widely applicable there the ways that we
earn money though the ways we earn money
patreon and sponsors and Adsense are
probably the most widely applicable
products and plan sales and twitch and
everything those are kind of more niche
yeah and we're not as experienced so
we're gonna move on so balancing
everything that we've talked about let's
like talk on that a little bit before we
wrap up yeah because there's definitely
a balance between like your monetization
your channel growth and how sustainable
you can't have all of those you can have
one or maybe two but you can't be like
at the beginning you can't be
sustainable good monetization and
growth unless you're very lucky or
skilled yeah I think like I think in the
beginning growth is more important than
monetization yes sustainability or
growth is probably more important this
is because like we were working our
butts off for a really long time and we
it feels like we're not now but then we
remind ourselves like oh yeah we still
work on weekends and from the time we
wake up till the time we go to bed so we
are still working our butts off compared
to most people and so sustainability in
terms of like how much you work I mean I
think it's something all youtubers a
little bit doesn't have somebody burn
out videos nowadays I think in the
beginning growth should be what you
focus on when you're getting to the
point where you foresee your ability to
make the switch to full time that's when
monetization kicks in can kick in and
become a bigger priority I don't think
you should ever monetize to the
detriment of growth because growth is a
long-term thing any any single sponsored
video that's a short-term thing anything
class comes sustainability because you
also have to like think about like the
sustainable methods of income you need
to like figure out how many videos you
can make and balance your life in
general I think that's one point that
we're getting to now like but in general
like building up that library of content
that will continue to bring in views
continue to bring in that growth that's
really important and then diversify all
of your incomes not having everything
and like all your eggs in one basket I
think both of those are really important
and I think that's kind of mainly yeah
we went through it all yeah I took us
like two hours yes a little longer than
we thought like oh man I've been we've
been wanting to make this podcast for so
long it was gonna be a video and then we
you know did it as a couple talks and
then it was gonna be a podcast and then
it just wasn't happening so I'm I'm glad
cuz cuz we do want to share the things
that we've learned you know there's a
lot of growing pains in the beginning we
don't want people to experience the pain
we experience if there's something that
we
can like a struggle we can help prevent
we want to help prevent it yeah and also
I think in general there are so many
awesome people out there like you guys
are awesome and you guys have important
knowledge or you're funny and there's
like people you can connect with online
and I think that YouTube is such an
exciting place to be to be a part of the
community and I think it'd be great to
get more people in on this and like
build everyone up I think that this is
definitely like a rising tides type is
that it I think this is a riding tide
type of situation and I think that like
the more people that get into this
better the more like mainstream it will
be the more legitimate it'll be I think
that that just good things will happen
yeah yeah yeah so um should we go back
to normal podcast mode and do our thing
of the week girls girls I might as well
let's do thing of the week
okay so my thing of the week is by far
thermochromic ink I even said it
correctly this time dude you didn't say
thermo chromatic so our video for that
was released a few days ago and I'm just
looking around all over the place so if
you haven't seen the video we turned our
controller into a mood ring
you think thermochromic it's amazing
it's so crazy to me that the magic of
mood rings can just be like used by
anyone and put on anything it's like
what the heck I could have a thermo
chromatic microphone I can have a thermo
chromatic like remote but it's such it's
such an interesting accessible science
thing that I thought was outside of our
reach but it's not yeah it is super cool
and very addicting it's very I just like
walk to our desk and I pick up it's an
Xbox 360 controller that we applied it
to for those of you who haven't seen it
and who are listening to it and not
watching yes
so my thing of the week is it a new
series or did we just newly discover it
its newly discovered it's actually not
that new not that new series on the bone
Appetit channel you guys have heard me
talk about the own Appetit channel
before but so great I love Claire and I
love Brad but there's this series that
they did that involved like a larger
group of people on the team and it's
called make it perfect or making perfect
making perfect and it's it's where the
it's like a five or six or some number
part series where they try to make the
perfect pizza Evan just held up a six
okay six part series where they try to
make the perfect pizza and they divide
up each of the tasks between the people
so the first step is making the dough in
Claire has to figure out how to make the
perfect dough and she goes and is taught
by these professional pizza dough makers
and it kind of continues for each part
of the series but it's also just like
hilarious and it's great production
value but the thing that like YouTube
vibes yeah they they strikes
good balance and I'm so excited for the
future of the platform like because I
know a lot of people fear companies
coming in but just like does it get it
they hire the right people they let them
have the freedom they let like good
content be made yeah and it just makes
me hopeful yeah and they don't over
polish it they just like enable people
to travel to Italy and like spend time
and money on the perfect pizza sauce
yeah I mean like looking through the
talk that we just gave they're doing all
the things very well yes in terms of
like consistency and like bon appetit
probably went to our talking probably so
I guess it's just like I I see a lot of
good things and what they do and it's
really exciting yeah but yeah it's an
awesome series we'll link to it it's our
we're in the middle of it right now I
think we're on episode 3 and usual
podcast will resume next Monday where we
have the topics and games and story
times and all of the fun things that you
guys like and we really appreciate you
guys listening and guys share this
around I don't want this to just get
hidden away anything like that sure this
specific yeah shared this one in
particular like this episode you know
wherever you think might work best but
like share it on all of your social on
any websites that you think might be
interested because I feel like this
information in its entirety doesn't get
shared often and I think that like the
whole story is so much more important
than just like a single like tip or hack
or whatever yeah actually the beginning
part of this I think that more people
might need to hear the foundational
stuff that we talked about so yeah
please and thank you
[Music]